[Music]
sup colonel oh nothing just avoiding my
mother why is that make sure you
go front to back I have a date tonight
oh I hate that you don't have arms you
got a weird family dude oh come
on man don't litter Gary the gardener
hates that what the heck is this what
you got there Colonel I don't know I
think it's a thumb well is it yours no
put it back it's none of our business
dude we found a thumb we should call the
cops absolutely not colonel why not
colonel when I was nine someone stole my
bike and you know what I did why'd you
do if any I called the cops and you know
what happened you got your bike back No
they arrested my dad turns out he'd
actually traded my bike for crack but
the point is we are not calling the cops
well what should we do we're gonna take
matters into our own hands a little
something I like to call street justice
all right okay okay how do we do the
street justice let's go see the one
person that knows everything that
happens in the neighborhood cat lady
care and that's how I learned I could
softball an egg in my that's great
cat lady Carol but we're here about the
thumb remember ah yes yes of course
well I have been hearing unsettling
noises coming from Dave's place every
Friday night today's Friday and that
means tonight will be Friday night looks
like we need to check out Dave's place
all right that's Dave's place let's
check it out this whole street justice
thing seems like a lot of work penny
plus this just feels dangerous what
feels dangerous oh nothing Dave didn't
see you there what do you guys do not to
set my place it's Freddy I don't like
people hanging outside my place and
Freddy why is that Dave what goes on on
Fridays nothing you'd be interested in
seeing especially you Qurna wait why me
it's a matter of your own special day
what the was that man did Dave just
threaten my flesh and blood
I don't know but Dave's acting guilty as
and look is that blood oh my god
well that proves it Vinny Dave's a
killer what are we gonna do we gotta
catch Dave in the act we got to go in
there oh that dude I'm not going in
there day's a killer fine I'll go in you
stay out here and keep a lookout if
anything shady goes down give me the
signal
now just call my phone all right Dave
where do you keep your dirty little
secrets
Oh No Oh No Vinnie Vinnie how did
he not get the signal oh oh that's right
oh yeah I'm an idiot
I have mozzarella sticks for after but I
accidentally drop the marinara sauce
outside earlier that explains the stain
so do you guys want to kick it up a
notch this week a drill-down Dave really
yeah I thought we're gonna have weird
sex it drove those aren't weird uh what
did you all have in mind I'm up for
anything as long as one of you calls my
dad on speaker in the middle of it the
only way I can come is if I'm sure I'm
disappointing my father uh-oh I know
that makes you guys like an uncracked
house what the well alright then
the Friday night let's commence oh
don't worry Benny help is on the
way
are you oh thank god you're here officer
what are you doing sneaking out Dave's
place there's something going on inside
yeah it's Friday that was here last week
you mean you're involved I wouldn't say
involved it was more like a
no-strings-attached type of deal then he
was right the cops can't be trusted
here you're dirty hey it's 2017 sex is a
canvas that each person can paint
however they want and there's nothing
dirty about that non-consensual
voyeurism however is another story
what now put your hands behind your back
scumbag Dave do you have any quilts I
don't think a towel is gonna soak this
up yeah just Chuck in the closet oh man
is this not my closet house is my closet
my mistake guys I'll just be going fanny
what the hell are you doing here I I
invited him mrs. pepper specs sorry I'm
late guys
just go along with it Denny I'll get you
out of this I told Vinny he should come
and surprise you all I figured it would
be a nice treat for the group well I
think we all agree that's pretty hot
well your timing couldn't be more
perfect this is usually when we take a
break and watch two people have slow
intimate sex with one another that won't
be a problem will it Vinny
why are you doing this just let this
happen
[Music]
hey man where have you been I was in
jail man you were right about the cops
by the way I'm all for street justice no
I I'm done with street justice I was I
was wrong man oh well if the cops
aren't good and street justice isn't
good what have we learned
uh I don't know man I guess stay away
from Dave's on Fridays and maybe don't
kiss your mom for a while what hey hey
yous guys hey it's Gary the gardener
what's up Gary the gardener happy you
seen on my thumb I cut him my thumb with
the shears and now I canna know a pic of
the weeds yeah we found a thumb yeah
it's up my ass dude why is it up your
ass I hid it from the cops when they
were processing me I didn't want him to
find the evidence evidence of what you
know for the street justice you really
don't understand street justice my thumb
is up your bot yeah
and I love it like mother like
son what nothing